vos invités mais tout d'abord on va
souligné cet engouement assez inhabituel
finalement de tout un pays pour une
couleur pour le bleu ce maillot bleu qui
aurait peut-être été un petit peu allez
on va dire un gars dans les rues il y a
quelques mois bien aujourd'hui c'est à
la mode c'est très tendance comme on dit
c'est la mayo magna que nous raconte
christelle bertrand laurent hamida non
seulement ces femmes-là supporter leur
mari mais pour la première fois elles
portent leur maillot elle montre
l'exemple soutiennent l'équipe de france
comme des milliers d'autres femmes plus
les joueurs tricolores passent les tours
plus les maillots souvent il y en aura
pas pour tout le monde l'entente
qu'adidas france on n'avait pas
effectivement largement misé sur le
maillot de l'équipe de france là on va
être un peu juste juste dans le nombre
est juste dans les tailles les magasins
sont proches de la rupture de stock
on veut aussi être beau avec ce maillot
mais c'est dur d'en trouver un qui vous
va comme un gant pourrait porter le
maillot des deux princes pour ward pour
quelle bêtise quelle équipe le support
des malades mois ils sont très
difficiles à obtenir
il n'est pas sur les charges et divers
je vois que grande taille manque le
maillot bleu blanc rouge est aussi
devenu un souvenir pour les supporters
étrangers
meilleure vente dans le magasin le match
ridan ronaldo est lancé à 350 francs le
tee shirt
les ventes ont quand même augmenté de
40% le rayon maillot se vide si la
france est en finale on va finir par
acheter son maillot sous le manteau on
peut aussi fabriquer sa propre tenue
les stylistes supporters ne sont jamais
à court d'imagination
il y en a même que ça fait pas mal
travailler du chapeau
le maillot est à la mode normal c'est
l'été c'est la coupe du monde
dans ce cas là la meilleure tenue c'est
le maillot de bain